welcome to Kaiba max is 100 seconds
sports edition who let the sports out
sports sports sports sports now Gabe and
I are guys so we obviously the love
sports but to be honest Gabe is not
actually as into sports as a lot of guys
really Gabe what's your favorite sport
MTV's rock and rock basketball your
favorite sport is a once in a year
celebrity exhibition match with made-up
rules that hasn't been played in 16
years who's your favorite athlete Peppa
yeah well we're here to talk about
Gilbert Arenas who's that he's a player
of course on the Washington Wizards what
is that and he's suspended right now
indefinitely for bringing unloaded guns
into the line oh they play the game with
loaded no not in trouble because guns
weren't loaded the guns were loaded the
Wizards would have just kicked him off
the team what does the wizard need with
a gun game what do you think this says
about role models in our country Dean
Cain would have never pulled a stunt
like this when he was playing for the
bricklayers I don't over the bricklayers
bricklayers declares and violators two
teams dragon Jack your favorite sport
has just two teams oh yeah how many
teams does your NBA you have 30 you
should 30 teams you're going to play for
like a week because Pauly Shore has a
week to take off every year for sports
to wrap it up do you think that on
account of the guns Gilbert arena should
ever be allowed to play basketball again
you're blowing this up allows you to
blow that whistle nope